des prix du pétrole négatif l'incroyable
s'est donc produit cette semaine avec la
chute à - 37 dollar du baril de brut
américain un plongeon historique l'excès
d'offre sur le marché est telle que
certains sont prêts à payer pour qu'on
les débarrassent de leur production
alors comment en est on arrivé là
peut-on l'expliquer par la seule crise
du coronavirus le secteur pétrolier
peut-il sont relevées on voit tout cela
avec vous l'économiste jacques sapir
bonsoir jacques bienvenu toujours avec
nous villa skype évidemment jacques que
se passe-t-il sur le marché du pétrole
alors stéphanie comme vous l'avez dit
l'économie l'épidémie du coït 19 et
surtout le confinement des principales
économies a eu un impact direct sur le
marché du pétrole avec une chute très
brutale de la demande mais ce n'est pas
la seule explication au jour
extraordinaire que nous venons de vivre
parce que au-delà de ce que j'appelle le
corona craque c'est à dire ce krach
pétroliers sur fond de coronavirus et
bien nous avons trois pays qui sont en
train de s'affronter sur le marché du
pétrole il ya l'arabie saoudite la
russie et les etats unis
et cet affrontement a eu un rôle
déterminant dans ce qui vient de se
passer alors jacky a tout d'abord une
question simple comment un bien matériel
comme le pétrole peut-il avoir un prix
négatif il faut nous expliquer car on a
parfois du mal à le croire
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est fini
tout d'abord il faut rappeler que quand
on parle du prix du pétrole
c'est en réalité une simplification il y
à des prix du pétrole alors
essentiellement il y en a deux bons
chrétiens n'a plus mais disons-le y en a
deux qui sont principaux qui servent un
petit peu de prix directeur le brent
pour le marché du pétrole qui est à
londres et le haut west texas
intermediate le double où tu y ailles
comme on dit dont le marché est aux
états unis
l'épisode des prix négatifs s'est
produit sur le double outillage et pas
sur le brent alors en plus il faut
savoir que les marchés du pétrole
sont ce que l'on appelle des marchés au
futur on achète par exemple une quantité
de pétrole en mars ou en avril pour être
livrés physiquement au début du mois de
mai alors jacquin qu'est ce que cela
veut dire de l'état de la demande aux
états unis par exemple
alors ce qui s'est passé et c'est fini
c'est qu'avec la baisse de la demande
les acheteurs ont cherché des réservoirs
pour stocker le pétrole qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas utiliser dans l'immédiat
or pratiquement toutes les capacités de
stockage sont aujourd'hui soit utilisés
soit loué et en particulier à
l'extrémité de l'oléoduc de l'oklahoma
où se font justement les transactions
sur le double il tient alors les gérer
les acteurs ont cherché désespérément à
se débarrasser des quantités de pétrole
qui ne pouvaient plus stockées et c'est
cela qui a provoqué justement cet
effondrement des prix et que le marché
est ce qu'on appelle un marché aux
futurs
les acheteurs ont cherché à revendre les
quantités qu'il avait acquise provoquant
ainsi des ventes à perte comme on dit
dans le jargon
ils ont vendu short et ce sont ses
ventes à pair qui a entraîné le prix au
dessous de zéro alors il faut comprendre
que cet épisode est largement le fait
tout d'abord d'une pénurie de moyens de
stockage mais aussi d'un affolement
spéculatifs sur un marché aux futurs
alors jacques on comprend mieux
effectivement comment on a pu arriver à
des prix négatifs mais ce que c'est
aussi le signe que la demande s'est
effondrée
et oui évidemment stephenie et si l'on
compare la les courbes des prix on voit
bien que ces dernières qui était au
dessus de 60 dollars le baril commence à
baisser à partir de la deuxième
quinzaine de janvier quand la chine se
décide à confiner sa population mais ce
que l'on voit aussi sur les courbes
c'est que à partie
du 6 mars la baisse commence à
s'accélérer et c'est ceci qui nous
indique que l'épidémie ducobu 19 n'est
pas la seule responsable de cette baisse
des prix
et que s'est-il passé jacques le 6 mars
alors le 6 mars nous avions à vienne en
autriche
une réunion des pays de l'opep à
laquelle était invité la russie
c'est ce que l'on appelle d'ailleurs le
format opep plus pays de l'opep plus la
route
cette réunion avait pour but de discuter
de nouvelles baisses de production pour
tenter justement de faire remonter les
cours
quand le ministre du pétrole russe
monsieur novak est arrivé à vienne
il a déclaré qu'il était impensable que
de nouvelles mesures soient décidées
tant que les états unis qui sont devenus
et ça c'est un changement important
depuis une dizaine d'années qui sont
devenu un exportateur de poids avec leur
pétrole de schiste ne prendrai pas leur
part justement dans ces baisses de
production l'arabie saoudite a alors
dénoncé les accords existants et décider
de pompey autant de pétrole que possible
afin de gagner des parts de marché et
c'est cela qui a provoqué ce qu'il faut
bien appeler une espèce de guerre des
prix au moment où justement la demande
mondiale se réduisait de près d'un tiers
sur fond de crise du coronavirus et
c'est cela qui a provoqué le plongeon
des prix oui c'est fait c'est cela qui a
provoqué le plongeon des prix le prix
calculé sur l' indice américain sur le
wti est passé rapidement sous la barre
des 30 dollars
les jours suivants le brun a suivi mais
ont décalé et c'est cette baisse des
prix qui a provoqué une véritable crise
alors c'était une crise industrielle aux
etats unis
mais jacques pourquoi précisément aux
états unis eh bien ces familles il faut
regarder le coût d'extraction des coûts
de production du pétrole de schiste aux
états unis
ce conte moyen varie de 23 à 36 dollars
le baril seulement voilà c'est une
moyenne
et pour 2
nombreuses petites et moyennes
compagnies le prix se situe plutôt entre
45 et 50 dollars le baril alors prix de
l' indice wta elle qui est inférieur à
30 dollars de très nombreuses petites
compagnies qui sont en général
lourdement endetté font faillite
d'ailleurs dès le début du mois d'avril
près d'un travailleur sur deux de
l'industrie pétrolière américaine avec
des licenciés avec un prix inférieur à
20 $ ce qui est la situation actuelle
est même largement en dessous par
moments de ces 20 dollars
c'est tout le secteur qui est sinistré
et c'est pourquoi
donald rhin a décidé de lancer un
programme spécial de soutien à
l'industrie du pétrole et du gaz et
qu'ils envisagent même d'interdire les
importations de pétrole aux états unis
alors on peut penser un chèque
logiquement que ça de suite des prix
fait également malo aux autres
producteurs
oui évidemment stéphanie la russie par
exemple dont le pétrole est rattachée à
lundi ce brain s'ouvre mais elle souffre
moins que les autres ne serait ce que
parce que son budget était calculée sur
un prix assez bas sur un prix de 40
dollars le baril et quelle à d'amples
réserves de change et il faut bien le
dire un système fiscal qui est très
protecteur pour les compagnies
pétrolières
mais néanmoins elle souffre aussi et
puis il faut parler de l'arabie saoudite
qui est certainement le pays qui
aujourd'hui est celui qui souffre
financièrement le plus et c'est pour ça
que les pays de l'opep plus ont décidé
finalement de réduction importante de la
production pour environ 10 millions de
barils par jour
alors est ce que ce sera suffisant non
c'est fait non il faudra aller plus loin
surtout il faudrait que les etats unis
eux aussi acceptent de s'engager dans un
cadre contraignant alors il faut dire
qu'il s'y prépare d'ailleurs car la
production a baissé d'environ 4 millions
de barils par jour
rien qu'aux états unis alors jacques
selon vous est-ce qu'un accord est
possible bien stéphanie un nouvel accord
et henry
it est inévitable même si on ne sait pas
encore sous quelle forme se manifestera
quelle forme prendra les états unis
n'ont guère d'autre choix que de se
coordonner avec leurs adversaires d'hier
il faut bien dire que la de ce point de
vue là la leçon a porté le marché du
pétrole va donc se réorganiser et cette
réorganisation se fera d'ailleurs en
parallèle avec le déconfinement des
grandes économies
il est clair que ça va prendre du temps
mais cette réorganisation est à terme
inévitable
merci jacques pour ses explications et
cette analyse de la crise des prix du
pétrole et à bientôt sur rt france